alright so this is my last meal for the
next five days i'm only going to have
water
no coffee no tea no
anything not even like supplements or
herbs or anything so i'm having sweet
potato and steamed broccoli
um mushrooms
and avocado with salt pepper and
everything seasoning and red pepper
it's actually really good i love sweet
potato so i just finished my dinner and
now i'm going to make some bananas and
almond butter for dessert and then
that's it uh
yeah tomorrow starts the fast and it
will be five days nothing but water
so i'm just gonna do dishes go to bed
and i'll see you guys tomorrow
so it's 10 a.m uh i actually woke up at
6 30 but then i promptly went back to
sleep um
i started reading and i guess without
the coffee i just
i just dozed off
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay so
day one i honestly didn't do much um
i took two really long naps i just woke
up from another one right now and i
worked on my computer for a little bit
sat outside for a little bit
i have a massive massive headache um i
didn't realize i was this addicted to
caffeine it's only 5 pm i'm actually not
hungry at all but
i do intermittent fasting here and there
not every day but
often enough that yeah i'm not hungry
i'm just like
suffering from this headache and
withdrawal from caffeine
but i i'm going to just make my bed and
um
yeah maybe work in bed and just try to
go to sleep and hopefully tomorrow will
be better
it is
day two
i just woke up my head hurts so bad oh
my gosh
once again
it is 10 a.m um but day two
and
as you can see my bed is still
i'm still in bed um
i'm feeling a little better but that's
because i cheated
i made coffee
my head was hurting so bad i literally
was just like curled up in a ball on the
bed and
i have work to do so i can't really just
take the five days off and not get
anything done
[Music]
i got a little day couch a day bed and
my desk
so i don't have to make my bed every
night
and
this is just my mattress folded over so
it's honestly like a giant pillow so
comfortable also just for reference i am
five foot nine and it's six feet from
here to here
[Music]
it is 5 30 p.m on day two and
i am feeling much much better i have
not that much of a headache very small
but i have been drinking diluted coffee
most of the afternoon
um like very small amount of coffee just
with hot water added to it but i am
starting to feel a little shaky so
uh i guess it's headache or the shakes
um but anyway i'm i have a lot more
energy so i'm kind of pounding out a lot
of work right now which is good it will
be interesting to see if i can fall
asleep tonight
because i feel super wired
[Music]
all right so yesterday this time i
was too tired to even get out of bed i
was like curled up in a ball and felt so
weak and now day two i have so much
energy and
i'm climbing up this ridge
to get a shot of the van and watch
sunset
i was just about to hike back down
because i thought sunset was over but
i was wrong
[Music]
day three
three pm uh i have so much energy um i
woke up feeling really really hungry and
i had a headache but as soon as i had
some coffee i just felt like super
charged and i've been working all
morning at my computer which is really
an unlikely occurrence for me because
i'm so easily distracted i finally
changed my shirt so i'm not as stinky
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
good morning guys it is day four of the
fast um i shot out of bed today at 5 30
so i have more energy than usual
and i am packing up the van getting it
ready to go i am heading into san diego
today
to
get some stuff done to the van so i'm
excited for that
uh but it will be my first time being
around people
and
food so that will be interesting i'm
just out for my little morning walk
this is where i've been parked for the
last three days
[Music]
[Applause]
all right guys i'm all showered and i'm
heading into san diego now i'm just
going to cut off from here and then i
will update you how i'm feeling tonight
um
it will be
the evening of day four so
yeah pretty stoked and i'll see you soon
[Music]
i am currently
spending the night in an auto shop um
locked into the garage everyone's gone
home and so that's a new experience it's
pretty cool though there's a bathroom so
that's awesome and an espresso machine
for the morning honestly today i've just
been on a high um driving out here and
just the whole day i've been feeling
great i feel very productive
and very i have a lot of mental clarity
i have one day left tomorrow friday
and
yeah
then i'll be done so
good night see you tomorrow
hey guys good morning so it is friday
and day five of the fast
i woke up in the auto shop and i left
about an hour ago so i'm just running
some errands right now got gas and now i
need to get groceries so i feel like
this is gonna be the hardest
thing i've dealt with so far in terms of
exercising willpower
uh
it's been tricky being in the city
because i keep driving past all these
great restaurants and i just wanna
oh man it's got me dreaming of food um i
cannot wait to eat tomorrow and actually
i'm i'm not sure but i think maybe i can
have some broth this evening and if
that's the case
i'm very excited i've never been so
excited for broth before
but to be perfectly honest with you guys
i woke up not feeling that great i felt
kind of nauseous stick to my stomach
lightheaded i'm nursing a coffee and
that's helping a little bit but we'll
see how things go throughout the rest of
the day
and yeah i'll keep you posted
[Music]
[Music]
so i stocked up on vegan cheese and i
got some veggies
some blueberries more vegan cheese um
some soup to break the fast with
coffee and blueberries here's my second
grocery run it's mostly produce and just
some more broth almond butter
and yeah i think i'm good to go now and
head out into the desert
[Music]
okay so i
made it back out to the desert from san
diego and
i did find out that i can eat tonight
because my last meal was sunday night so
technically i can have my first meal
tonight
and i'll be honest as soon as i found
that out i've become completely fixated
on food
i'm like grumpy and irritable and all i
can think about is that first bite
so
i am just like counting down the time i
have another three hours to go
or actually two hours now so that's good
now i'm gonna go shoot for a client
during sunset and then
my five-day fast will be done and i can
eat so excited thank you
for sticking around if you are still
here i know this is a long vlog it's
going to be different for everyone if
you attempt this
but
yeah
what a wild experience i honestly can't
believe i've gone five days without food
like that's insane
to me anyway but all right let's let's
get out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so some of you might be wondering why i
am eating such a small amount of food
and the reason is after not eating for
so long your digestive system has
basically shut down so i kind of want to
slowly reboot it and not overload my
system right away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so i'm now filming a whole month later
after the fast and i just want to show
you guys where i am right now it's so
beautiful
and here's the full moon rising
over the desert it's so pretty i know
that this video is a little different
than usual but um it's part of my
experience out here in the van so i just
thought i'd share it and i actually have
tried a five-day fast before but in a
house and i failed um
probably just because there was food in
the cupboard and the fridge and it was
too tempting so
i found that by eating all the food that
i had in the van and then not grocery
shopping and driving out to the desert
that did the trick and
i'd also i'm in no way recommending this
i am not a doctor i'm not a nutritionist
i feel like i need a thousand
disclaimers here um this was just my
experience and i just thought i'd throw
it out there in case any of you are
interested i did learn a few things
first of all i am addicted to coffee and
i really need to pay attention to my
consumption and maybe start to lay off
the coffee a little bit number two i am
actually capable of going five whole
days without food without dying which
is good to know number three i spend a
lot of time and energy on food
thinking about food shopping for food
preparing food eating food cleaning up
after food all of those things they take
a lot of time money and energy and you
know it does make sense um a lot of big
food companies have incentive to
convince us that we should be eating all
day every day i think everyone should be
free to make whatever choice is best for
them and this fasting experiment was
just a way for me to personally push my
boundaries and see what i'm capable of
it was also a new way of incorporating
minimalism into my life which is hugely
important to me i believe in less but
better less stuff more freedom fewer
commitments more time for things that
matter and when it comes to food
quality over quantity would i do it
again yes definitely it was an amazing
reset for my taste buds and just
for my appreciation for food in general
would i recommend it i think you have to
do what's right for you and what's safe
and healthy for you and you know like i
said i'm not a nutritionist i'm not a
doctor i am a 35 year old woman living
in a van down by the river so there's
that in my personal opinion i think
there are some incredible health
benefits to fasting and it's definitely
worth exploring if it's something you're
interested in and you know just go at
your own pace okay that's enough talking
i talked a lot in this video but it oh
my gosh the view outside is insane so
i'm gonna go and i will catch you guys
next time
[Music]
you